what surprised you about Dave's scripts
that you were not expecting going in
that I had to wait so long in between
them
it was so painful it was so exciting
reading this and you know getting that
continuation of a story from Rebels
um and the surprises of so many of the
different characters that were coming
through but also just like
so nice to Deep dive into where they're
at emotionally
and you didn't get to see that so much
on we didn't get to explore that anyway
so much on Mandalorian and you know on
Boba Fett you know it was sort of like
hints at it but I think you get to see
like what that sacrifice that they're
kind of still grappling with and the
vigilance that it takes for them to
still know that there's a threat out
there that they have to be on top of you
know it's just it's um it's lonely
business you know what I mean to kind of
be out there fighting a threat that
people don't even believe is real and uh
and I think it's it's it's really
exciting as we were kind of going along
to see just how it was seated and the
context of it and the subtext of it for
the fans who know and the fans who don't
um it was just really nice you know this
is a character who can be implacable
almost because she's so Fierce and she's
so capable but you know she's she's not
finished with her journey you know she's
still she might be wiser but she's not
done and so it I think it was just
really nice to kind of explore some of
yeah some of some of the the
tensions that that exist there you know
she's gone through a lot we all know for
the for the fans who knows you know
she's gone through a lot and so it's
nice to be able to explore that and kind
of get into it so the first season I
don't know it's either eight or ten
episodes something around there
obviously the whole season is going to
be awesome but of the eight or ten
episodes is there one which is the one
that you're most looking forward to
fancying
in the one to five episodes I don't know
I mean I'm kidding whatever whatever the
amount of the number because I really
don't know nice I feel like you're gonna
like look back in the video and see like
when did her eye dilate or something
um you know I think
um
damn I mean the first one really starts
off really strong
but I'll say I have a favorite
it might be a favorite but I have I
don't really think about it is it the
finale or is it during the season
there might be
an episode that I really like a lot yeah
I won't push you anymore uh thank you
for your time I'm really looking forward
maybe not so much I don't think that was
subtle but